I need you to become the man you always
meant to be not next year not tomorrow
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
talk about sir Jaime Lannister as I'm
sure most of you know by now I have made
many videos about Jaime Lannister before
in some of those videos I have talked
about Jaime Lannister getting some
redemption before the story ends I have
also talked about the white book which
is also known as the book of brothers
every Knight who has ever served in the
Kingsguard has a page in the book on
which his deeds are written down as we
all know Jaime Lannister has his own
page in the book only his page has a
very big stain on it because as a member
of the Kingsguard Jaime killed the king
he swore an oath to protect this has
haunted Jaime for a very long time when
he murdered the Mad King he said that it
felt like justice but almost everyone
else saw it as a betrayal when I watched
the Mad King die I remembered him
laughing as your father
itself at justice
so will you tell yourself annoying you
know servants of Justice that you were
avenging my father and you shove your
sword in Aerys Targaryen back ever since
that day Jaime has been known as the
Kingslayer a name he has grown to
despise when you hear them whispering
Kingslayer behind your back doesn't it
bother you
of course it bothers me the lion doesn't
concern himself with the opinions of a
sheep if you have seen some of my other
videos about Jaime Lannister then you
would know that he often thinks about
the white book whether he wants to admit
it or not
Jaime is bothered by the fact that
people only think of him as the
Kingslayer and he might even be worried
that his pages in the white book will
not contain any other good deeds so what
I want to talk about today is what are
some of the other things Jaime can do to
be remembered as an honorable man most
of you should already know that I think
Jaime will most likely save a member of
House Stark from getting killed but are
there any other things he can do a
little over a year ago I made a video on
this topic but not too many people had
seen that video mostly because my
channel was much smaller at the time now
that we are getting closer to the final
season more fans are starting to get
excited about the return of the show so
I want to throw an idea back out there
to see if some people think it's
possible as we head into the final
season I have a few different ideas for
Jaime Lannister's character one of these
ideas could actually kill a few
different birds with one stone so let's
get into it
at the beginning of the series Jaime was
one of the most hated characters in all
of Westeros he was blinded by his own
love for his sister that drove him to do
just about anything to make sure that no
one came in between them as we saw in
the very first episode of the show Jaime
attempted to silence bran stark by
killing him just to make sure that no
one found out he was sleeping with his
sister a few episodes later Jaime even
said that he would kill anyone that
tried to get in their way which was
pretty obvious at the time but over the
years Jaime has slowly started to change
and see his sister for who she truly is
now that he has left Cersei I don't
think he would ever allow her to
manipulate him again in my opinion I
think Jaime is destined for greatness
mostly based on his characters
progression over the year
as we all know Jamie has had some
setbacks mostly due to Circe's influence
over him but now that he's left her I
think he can do much better by the time
the show comes to an end
I think Jamie will be a completely
different person or at least I hope so
I think most people believe Jamie will
be the one to kill Cersei I also happen
to believe this is a very good
possibility but I also know of a way
that Jaime can do this that would make
sense because it would also repeat
history in a few different ways as of
right now Jaime Lannister is most likely
on his way to Winterfell to live up to
his end of the agreement by helping Jon
and Daenerys defeat the night king
during the dragonpit scene Cersei agreed
to help them by sending all of her men
north but as we all know Cersei lied she
isn't gonna be sending them any men and
she actually hopes that the army of the
Dead invades the north she hopes they
can help her to feed her enemies this
made Jaime sick to his stomach because
he knows they cannot defeat Danny's
dragons or the army of the Dead by
themselves even though Cersei told him
that she paid for 20,000 mercenaries
from the golden company Jaime still
doesn't think this is a very good idea
with the army of the Dead marching south
Jaime knows that they need to band
together but Cersei refuses to see it
any other way
either way Jaime Lannister plans on
keeping his word so he's heading north
to fight the army of the Dead but
eventually all of them will have to come
south again to take care of Cersei
however if they one are off the Iron
Throne they will have to rip it from her
cold dead fingers which I believe they
will do as of right now you're on
Greyjoy is on its way to pick up the
golden company and bring them back to
King's Landing but I think Cersei is
gonna be in for a big surprise when she
realizes the golden company do not want
to fight for her many people believe
that the golden company will abandon
Cersei to join forces with the Targaryen
if that happens
Cersei will become extremely desperate
which will most likely cause her to do
something drastic to ensure that no one
else can have the Iron Throne this is
what I think Jaime Lannister can come
into play
the first problem Cersei faces could
potentially lie with the go-to company
like I said the golden company have a
reputation for never breaking a contract
but there is an example of this
happening in the books instead of
honoring their contract they decided to
sail to Westeros instead with the
character many believed to be Aegon
Targaryen
now that we know Jon Snow's real name is
targaryen perhaps something very similar
can happen again next season if the
golden company break their contract and
pledged their allegiance to the
Targaryen instead this would obviously
back Cersei into a corner this could
begin a series of events that lead
Cersei into turning King's Landing into
a ticking time bomb
just like the Mad King Aerys did we
already know there's wildfire underneath
the city and I happen to believe there
is a hell of a lot more but Jaime
Lannister can use Circe's desperation to
his advantage
this is when Jaime can seize King's
Landing just like his father did then
kill Cersei Lannister just like he did
with the Mad King history would repeat
but this time people would definitely
know that Jaime did it for the good of
the city and most importantly the realm
during Robert's rebellion Tywin
Lannister was the hand of the king he
was actually the hand to the king for
over 20 years but Tywin Lannister gave
up that position when the Mad King made
Jaime Lannister a member of the
Kingsguard as we all know Tywin
Lannister wanted Jaime to be able to
carry on the family's legacy when he was
made a member of the Kingsguard that
crippled Jaime's chances of ever having
a legitimate family of his own the Mad
King took those rights away along with
inheriting any lands or titles from his
father as you can imagine this really
pissed high went off Tywin left King's
Landing in a fury and rode back to
casually rock I'll make sure you
understand that when I won your war for
you my father won the real war he killed
Prince Rhaegar he took the crown while
you hid on a costly Rock during Robert's
rebellion when the Mad King needed some
help
Tywin stayed out of the fight until the
perfect opportunity arose when Robert
Baratheon killed Rhaegar Targaryen on
the Trident this made the rest of
Rhaegar army retreat this gave Robert
and Ned a clear path to King's Landing
where they then could remove the Mad
King from the Iron Throne
so when Tywin heard that Rhaegar died on
the battlefield he knew the war was
about to be over
he knew the Targaryen 's were in a tough
spot so he gathered up his man and he
headed for the gates of King's Landing
the Mad King had his Pyromancer placed
wildfire all over the city underground
when he knew he was running at a time he
told his Pyromancer to light the
wildfire that way he could destroy the
city before
ever having to step down his king he
wasn't about to just hand over the Iron
Throne
and it seems like Cersei plans on doing
the same thing so as soon as Tywin made
it to the gates of King's Landing
he was able to trick the Mad King into
letting him and his men inside Tywin
made it look like he was there to help
but he had a plan of his own that's when
Tywin ordered the mountain to kill
rygaard's wife and children and
beautiful noble Rhaegar Targaryen left
her for another woman that started a war
and the war ended right here when your
father's army took the city actually get
butchered those children my nephew a
nice carved them up and wrapped them in
Lannister cloaks when the Mad King
realized what was happening
he told his Pyromancer what to do but
Jaime Lannister wasn't about to allow
that to happen
he killed the Pyromancer before he could
set off the Wildfire then he killed the
Mad King
since we know Cersei Lannister will
never step down as Queen she might do
something very similar especially if the
golden company breaks their contract
Cersei would have very few men if that
happened the Greyjoy's might have a very
big fleet of ships but they are nowhere
near as good as fighting on the land as
they are out at sea so when Cersei gets
backed into a corner what does she do
with no-one left by her side she would
basically have no choice since she
doesn't want to negotiate a big battle
taking place in King's Landing was
already foreshadowed back in the second
season when Daenerys entered the house
of the undying before that happens
Cersei will most likely have the city on
lockdown that way no one can enter but
this is when Jaime Lannister can do his
good deed Jaime can show back up at the
gates in his Lannister uniform and have
them send more to Cersei saying that
he's there to help running out of
options
Cersei would let him in at this point
Cersei would be very desperate and still
having feelings for Jaime she's gonna
want him by her side once he's inside
the city he can go and kill the
Pyromancer
who is Qyburn right now then he can go
kill the Mad King who is Cersei right
now with Tywin's trick to gain access
inside King's Landing history repeats
once again Jaime Lannister can save the
city and its people from
total destruction he can also fulfill
the valonqar prophecy at the same time
then his pages in the white ball can be
filled with all the good deeds so Jaime
Lannister knighted and named to the
Kingsguard in his 16th year at the sack
of King's Landing murdered his King
Aerys ii pardoned by Robert Baratheon
thereafter known as the Kingslayer
it's the duty of the Lord commands to
fill those pages there's still room left
in mine maybe then people would believe
the story about why he killed the Mad
King and even as I said in a previous
video bran stark can even go back and
see what really happened that day he
would no longer be known as the
Kingslayer but instead the true savior
of King's Landing twice bran stark and
tell everyone the truth about Jaime
Lannister which would be kind of crazy
considering Jaime did try to kill brand
but let me know what you think
personally I think this would be a
really cool way to end Cersei and Jaime
story arcs but let me know if you think
something like this is possible or do
you have a different scenario of your
own anyways I want to thank everyone for
watching today's video I really
appreciate that and also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting the
channel it truly means a lot to me I
hope you all have a great day I'll see
you soon bye
[Music]